foreign
this show today is a special show
do not miss this thing
so buckle up put your earphones in and
uh turn the turn the volume up a little
bit and stay tuned for my conversation
with the great Dr Peter attia
[Music]
what is going on this is John with the
Dr John deloney show
sure we talked with real people who are
going with struggle with real stuff
trying to figure out what in the world
to do next and in a sea of nonsense
nonsense about health and wellness and
Fitness Nutrition and mental health and
emotional health and blah blah blah
I'm dedicated to I dedicated my life to
trying to cut through some of that
nonsense
this show today is a special show
do not miss this thing
when we laid out like the idea that I
was gonna have my own show and we sat
down with a team and it was back in the
OG days with Kelly and James Childs in
the whole gang
and we sat down and said what's a dream
list of people that you would one day
like to have on your show
the number one guy
number one
was Dr Peter attia Dr ATI is a guy who
has I found in 2011 2012 when I was a
ball of chaos my life was Mayhem
and
he was just starting to write blogs and
just starting to put information out and
just starting to challenge conventional
wisdom about medicine and challenge
conventional wisdom about diet
and I found him to be a cup of cold
water in the desert and over the last
five six years he has transformed into
one of the world's leading voices
um and how we look at medicine how we
look at being well how we look at
emotional health and physical health and
he wrote this new book which is an
absolute
Masterpiece it's one of the rare books
that I believe should be on every shelf
in every home in America the book's
called outlive the science and art of
longevity by Dr Peter attia it's a
masterpiece it's so good and I'll tell
you this
um there's a couple of chapters in here
that are worth the price of admission
alone here's how much I
um value this book I borrowed my own
money now if you don't know behind
closed doors Publishers will send books
try to get you on media Outlets it
didn't work this way I bought this book
and
did my best to get a hold of Dr Tia
because I wanted him to be on this show
um a couple of days after we recorded
the show I saw he was on Oprah right so
he has left the stratosphere but he did
give an hour of his precious time for
me and our team and our 17 or 18
listeners of this show
to really take a deep dive and we talk
about some hard stuff
um
he's one of the most gracious men in the
country I'm so grateful you get to hear
this conversation
um and I don't really hold back ask a
lot of hard questions and
um it's one of the great blessings of my
life so far so buckle up put your
earphones in and uh turn the turn the
volume up a little bit and stay tuned
for my conversation with the great Dr
Peter attia
so we're going to dive into this
um and I've intentionally not listened
to some of the media you've done on this
book because I wanted to
just talk about this book and your work
globally in ways that it's impacted me
because I think that's that's the most
honest way we can talk to our listeners
um but I do want to touch on this real
important I mean the Cornerstone of this
book can you talk about the four
horsemen
um you've had a ringside seat both as an
in one you experiment on yourself and
countless page patients we all end up
dead but many of us die long before they
code they code us and many of us live
less than our best up in these last days
so can you talk about the four horsemen
what you're what you even mean by all
that
well I mean the the four horsemen are
just referenced to kind of the the four
big chronic diseases that you know
shorten lifespan which is a part of
longevity the other part being Health
span which I'm sure we'll talk about as
well
um but you know for the most part if
you're over 40 and you're a non-smoker
and you don't engage in really really
Ultra risky behavior
um unfortunately that includes you know
using you know illicit drugs now given
fentanyl poisoning
um there's pretty much a 80 plus percent
chance you're going to succumb to one of
these Horsemen cardiovascular disease
neurodegenerative disease cancer and
metabolic disease the most obvious
example of this is type 2 diabetes but
of course long before you get to type 2
diabetes you've passed through the
station of non-alcoholic fatty liver
disease insulin resistance
hyperinsulinemia and so collectively uh
at least one way to think about how do I
live longer is understanding what are
the impediments to a longer life and for
most of us it's going to be one of the
horsemen
so it's a moment of shame that I carry
around with me
um I spent 20 years working in higher ed
with scientists and professors as a dean
of students as a professor
I spent my years with some of the most
lovely caring wonderful people who are
trying to solve big problems
when I left that ecosystem if you will
and came here and as my 12 year old son
says Dad you're just a YouTuber now
as I transitioned to this new ecosystem
I've been
frustrated humbled whatever word you
want to say
by the fact that I was talking over
people for 20 years
um as as quote unquote as we tried to
dumb things down or put things on the
bottom shelf where people understand I I
just was talking over people and it
wasn't until I was sitting with single
moms and truck drivers who just want to
be better dads
um just want to be better moms that I
realized man this this is such there's
such a a Chasm here
how do we bridge that Chasm between like
what even is metabolic disease and the
single mom with three kids who's just
trying to say dude can you just give me
one or two things so I can breathe right
what that this feels like such a gap
there and I don't know how to bridge it
I don't know that I have the answer to
that John I mean I think
I would say the way to bridge it is to
uh in a resource confined world and for
most people the most precious resource
is time not money so the question is
how much time does it take to reduce
risk of these things and and
you know live you know take take action
today to have more time later I mean
that's basically what you're doing here
it's it's a Time swap so you're and it
is an Arbitrage in your favor so the the
more time you can put into this thing
now the more absolute time you get on
the back end and the better that quality
of time I think most people care more
about the quality piece than the
absolute piece I think if most people
were really confronted with
what it means to suffer in quality of
life cognitive suffer physical suffer
um
they would accept that it's a really
worthwhile decision to make when you
still have your health to do something
about it
and you know what one does about it is a
function of how much time a person has
but you know you have to compare it to
the alternative right so
if a person is exercising not at all
right which is more more people than not
are not exercising at all
um that's the lowest piece of hanging
fruit there is out there I mean going
from nothing to three hours a week of
exercise
Cuts your risk of all-cause mortality
meaning death of any cause certainly
inclusive of the horsemen cuts that risk
down by 50 in any given year golly I
mean we just don't have other things
that compare to that so there there is
on the market on planet earth that could
touch that
no not even close so so you know I'm not
going to be the one that sits here and
says that is or isn't worth it but but
those are just the facts and I I don't I
don't see it as my my job frankly to to
to to tell people what to do I I think
it's just I'd like to lay out the info
and let people decide how much of the
menu they want
you mentioned um
gosh it may have been on your show a
while back this idea of reframing the
Paradigm between
we've gotten really good in our medical
system and in our mental health system
um which again the fact that they're
separate's a whole other conversation
at when somebody gets sick
coming in and solving that problem and
you've completely shifted the Paradigm
to what if we prolonged the time we were
healthy and well and whole before we got
sick
in the face of just live your life and
we've got you you can eat what you want
you don't have to move you can just just
just absorb life and then when it when
it hits you will be there how do you
flip that Paradigm on its head is it
just what you said just give people the
alternative like hey you could live a
like just a qualitatively better life if
you started doing something well I mean
I think it depends on if you're trying
to think through that at the policy
level or at the individual level so
in some ways it's easier to explain
what's wrong at the policy level because
it's the way medicine 2.0 which is how I
described it in the book is is is is
fundamentally constructed so medicine
2.0
came along to solve
a certain type of problem which was what
what I call fast death so for most of
our history we die to fast death you you
basically died from infections and
Trauma that that was how we died up
until you know several hundred years ago
and we had no treatments for those
things that really worked
and in the span of a couple of
generations we've figured out how to
solve those problems and it's been
miraculous it's literally doubled human
lifespan from about 40 to 80.
um but in the same time we've
demonstrated that that Playbook which
you describe as
come to me when the problem is really
bad we have a solution to fix it that
problem doesn't work for slow death
that problem doesn't work very well for
cancer doesn't work very well for
Alzheimer's disease it doesn't work very
well for all these chronic diseases
it works slightly
right meaning we do extend the period of
time people can live with disease now
but if you actually look at the data
which I I think I have an entire chapter
devoted to this I think it's chapter
four
I go through and I think make the case
that that strategy won't work in fact
the only strategy is the reverse you
have to extend the period of time that
you are free of disease not the period
of time that you have disease so
medicine 3.0 is about lengthening the
period of time before you have disease
and Medicine 2.0 which is in my book
failed against chronic diseases is the
opposite that feels like something if
you distill from policy done to
individual that feels like something
that needs to be implemented starting in
kindergarten
with how we move and how we sit and just
the life lessons that say here's what
this looks like
or I mean it's got to start in the home
too but sometimes that's a tough that's
a tough sell yeah I mean it's got it's
got to be everywhere I mean our Health
Care system isn't set up for that
um so that's unfortunately I think it's
much easier to solve the individual
problem and that's why this book is
written for the individual not for the
policy maker it's basically my way of
saying I'm not convinced we will solve
this problem at the policy level
um but at a minimum even though it's
harder if you want to solve it for
yourself than if the system solved it
for you
we're not going to wait around for the
system to solve it you're gonna you're
gonna you know here's a playbook for how
to solve it yourself
you've been at the medical level I've
been behind closed doors
um I've done the same with the mental
health professionals incredible people
trying to do incredible hard things
where have you seen the roots of this
entropy and we all know we all see the
data and we're gonna go do it anyway
and so I think of something like
well I'll let you answer because I can
kind of get on a little tangent here
well do you mean
um why is the current system the way it
is I I have not met a doctor
friend researcher or somebody that I'm
going to see that likes the state of
things
and likes the Machinery with which they
operate I don't know a mental health
professional that is that is Keen on
having to label everybody that walks in
their door
but the but the system gets stuck there
right and it has to take a a rogue
member like yourself to just break off
and say I gotta do something different
yeah and and let's be clear I'm not
alone a lot of people of course of
course chosen to do this but uh I mean
in a word money right so
um you the system is built around uh a
system of diagnosis treatment and
billing and we have an insurance system
that reimburses and this is true whether
it's private insurance or whether it's
public Insurance I.E CMS medicare
Medicaid
um all of that reimbursement is still
based on the same algorithm
which is what you just described so you
you have to come up with a diagnosis you
have to have an ICD-10 code on this
thing to get billed and
um our treatments are not we don't
reimburse for exercise we don't
reimburse for nutrition we don't
reimburse for sleep we don't reimburse
for emotional health we reimburse for
mental health and there is a difference
um and even within that we think about
it through you know the DSM-5 as opposed
to maybe a more nuanced look at you know
what what constitutes emotional health
so
I don't say that to sound
um
you know jaded I just think that that's
the truth of it is the reality and I
think that I think everything is just
predicated around a system but at the
end of the day if you're a doctor you
have to make a living and if your choice
is
this is the way I'm going to make a
living because this is the way the
system works then it's the way it's
going to work and yes if you're willing
to take more risk and go out there and
go outside the system you you can do
something a little bit different but
it's really not scalable right and the
reason it's not scalable is because
you know the majority of people need
their health insurance to be covered by
another entity
[Music]
this show is sponsored at our help folks
take a minute to think about how much
time you spend on yourself it's easy to
get caught up in what people need from
you and want from you and never think
about what you need and then you end up
too stretched out burned out all of the
madness of our current world resting on
your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself they help you set boundaries
and still have energy left to help
others without leaving yourself behind
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
totally online to fit into your schedule
you just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with the licensed
therapist and you can switch therapists
at any time for no additional charge so
find more balance find Wellness with
better help visit betterhelp.com deloney
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
I want to take a little bit of a left
turn here
so
actually pull pull this apart for us
mental health and emotional health
you're very careful to speak about
emotional health which I appreciate
um what are the what's the Nuance there
well I mean I think
when we talk about mental health we're
typically talking about
diagnosable conditions and these are
things that obviously people are
familiar with you know depression
anxiety things of that nature but of
course it also includes more severe
conditions schizophrenia bipolar
hypomania or personality disorders you
know narcissistic personality disorder
borderline personality disorder these
things all probably fit somewhere under
the umbrella of mental health
um
emotion and and those are very
significant right so the prevalence of
these things within the population to
varying degrees is significant
um and there it's not necessarily always
to the point where it's pathological
right I mean a person can have some
anxiety and it not be a pathological
condition so
um
you know the system does tend to
pathologize these things a bit
I I'm I'm not I know nothing about that
system so there's nothing in you know
there's nothing I write about that
there's nothing I speak about there I
know nothing about that that is not my
field of training uh what I'm really
talking about is something that's a
little more Broad and something that
every person ought to be considering
which is emotional health and emotional
health
um well inclusive of mental health
should there be mental health issues is
probably a lot broader and it probably
includes
more it includes for example
um
happiness and joy fulfillment sense of
purpose
the state of one's relationships the
state of one's relationships not just
with others but with oneself
um
these things are probably the lattice
upon which
one really defines the quality of their
life in other words if if the State of
Affairs in emotional health is poor
it's hard to make up for it if not
impossible with anything else
um I want to double click like what you
just said is really powerful because we
try to solve that with infinite number
of
charlatan hacks
and that's that's really important
charlatan hacks I mean I I think I think
we we would all try to solve those
things we we would all try to fill a
void there with
other things that on the surface seem
reasonable work money success
um you know shallow friendships
um the approval of others you know
there's all sorts of things that we
would we we will try to use to fill a
void if there is indeed a void there and
um
I think if most people are being honest
and they think about it they realize
that
nothing else matters if that is in
disarray
um
and therefore I that's why I felt that
that at least warranted some discussion
in a book on longevity it feels like as
a mental health guy feels like a more
honest representation of what the
mental health Diagnostics are attempting
to do
which is paint a picture of an arc of
behavior or an arc of a body responding
but emotional health seems like a much
more honest way to look at it but again
it's hard to codify that and to
reimburse for how much joy do you have
versus how many times have you felt
anxious in the last six months that's a
um
golly man I think that is Paradigm
reframing in a in a really powerful way
because if I'm seeking joy and I'm
seeking Beauty and I'm seeking happiness
and I'm seeking good relationships
that's going to impact movement and
sleep and metabolic health and eating
and also staying up too late and having
some beers when a buddy comes into town
it's going to impact all of that
as the I don't know that she feels like
window number one and not window number
after thought after you get all these
other things lined up
uh that's completely true
um so I think that those are those are
basically different sides of the same
coin so on the one hand
if that emotional house is not in order
for many people not for all but for many
people it becomes difficult to take care
of their physical health as well
and many of the behaviors that are
self-destructive to to one's physical
health whether it be with respect to
food exercise drugs
um anti-social behavior all these things
stem from
a breakdown in that emotional health uh
you know bucket and then similarly that
breakdown is also leading to just misery
so now you have
poor physical health and poor emotional
health but the core problem is often the
same
and and I guess the heartbreaking part
for me and I know you've sat with
countless patients just kneecap to
kneecap
is when the ticker tape running
underneath your life is
that you're worthless or you're a piece
of crap or it's your fault that your
parents fill in the blank
choosing misery is a it that makes sense
that's a deserved punishment for your
life and so there's almost
there's this really important need to
change some of those core messages so
that I believe I've got value Beyond
misery or I don't have a picture for
what non-misery life looks like my mom's
smoke my dad smoked my dad yelled my mom
left us every couple of weeks that's
just what I that's the picture I got
that's the that's the scale and being
able to paint a new picture that says
man there's there's
there's a there's there's something else
here this is tough man
yeah and I I think it's I think it's all
of that and I think it's also
um believing that you can change the the
current state
um internally I mean right so so it's
it's one thing to think yeah I can get
out of this situation but a lot of times
you can escape one situation you find
yourself in a better place by external
metrics but the internal milieu is the
same
and I think that's the harder one to
confront and I think it's also the
harder one for people certainly for me
to believe that there's that there's
plasticity there that that thing can
change
there's been few scarier moments than
last year my wife and I sat on our front
porch out here we live on some Acres out
here in Nashville
overlooking our Dream we'd we'd we'd had
a financial year that neither of our
families just like family trees could
have imagined
and we just lost a friend our marriage
was pretty tough man like it's tough to
think because man I really hedged my
bets on these metrics and they didn't
like the amount of money in the account
and the amount of this it didn't come
through and it's harrowing a guy like me
thinking I got all the answers and I got
there and it wasn't there right what's
that old saying like I went with me
right I showed up there too and until I
deal with that guy there is no
there's no dollar amount that brings
peace to my home right
yeah yeah all right so let's turn left
here
how do we find balance and this is a
global dratia question here how do we
find balance
between achievement on a grand scale and
here's what I mean you have accomplished
many wonderful things and as I as I
embarrassed myself in the intro here you
have done so much productivity wise and
you've presented it to the world in a
way that helps all these people
and I want my buddy Peter to have a
great marriage and like his kids want to
come home when they graduate college and
want to come hang out
at what point how do you find that
balance I feel like the The Narrative is
one of two ways one we get one narrative
which is
crush it and kill it and go and go and
go and go and go and if you have a
feeling and if you get tired it's
because you're weak and you seem to suck
it up and the other feel the other path
is
the seven million men who just said dude
I'm out of the workforce I'm out of here
or quiet quitting or sitting at home or
just like you mentioned earlier I just
feel so disempowered I man I'm I'm out
there has to be a new third way here to
both
achieve things do well contribute to
society and not melt yourself in the
process but if I look back on those who
have really made a mark on society
they left a wake behind him and I don't
know how to find that balance and this
is a macro this is this is Dr Atia a
global voice on you know best-selling
author but it's also
Tim the Boy Scout leader who's got two
kids right
yeah I mean I I I don't
I guess I can only speak to this from my
experience I I certainly felt the
need to uh as the way I described it
when I was kind of younger and my wife
will talk about this if
um you know the way I would talk about
it to her when we first got married is I
wanted to build a skyscraper and I just
said look if you go into
if you if you look out of the world it's
mostly just townhouses and there's only
a few skyscrapers out there and there's
there's people who have done
unbelievable exceptional things that
have stood out and I want to be one of
those I want to build this skyscraper
and I just was adamant about that I had
to do this I had to build a skyscraper
and
um
there's just there's just no question in
my mind now where that was coming from
and how unhealthy that was and that's
kind of the irony of it is I think a lot
of people who do build skyscrapers
whether it means through some enormous
financial success or even through
something more productive right like you
know literally creating a technology
that is you know valuable
um
a lot of times there's probably a void
that's being filled there and and while
the world may benefit from what they've
done it might not necessarily be
um ultimately filling that void
I I can only say that today
um I first of all I realize how kind of
grandiose that aspiration is and and
that's not surprising it's congruent and
consistent with everything that I now
know about myself and my past and it's
not an accident that I would
find myself in a very grandiose position
as the defense mechanism
I also realized that statistically
the probability that any one of us
really matter cosmically is is pretty
much zero right so like we just have to
be honest and think about this which is
you know even when you think about the
most significant people dying it it just
it
you know to borrow that phrase bending
the Ark of the universe I'm not sure who
first used that expression very few
people bend the Ark of the universe and
I'm much happier today not trying to
build a skyscraper and not trying to
bend the Ark of the universe because
first of all I just know it's it wasn't
making me any happier being in pursuit
of it two if I'm going to be brutally
honest I wasn't going to do it
and three it's allowing me to optimize
more for something that I think is more
valuable which is the you know time I
have with the people who matter most to
me
and
I don't think I have this figured out
like I I mean I'm also I'm clearly
trying to be the guy in the middle I'm
not retiring I'm not saying I'm not
going to work I'm not
I'm not working 40 hours a week right
you know I'm not taking weekends off to
do
you know to not work I mean I'm still
I'm still working probably harder than I
would even like to work but
um
it's just it's just different it doesn't
feel like I'm trying to change the world
um and
I I think my priorities have really
shifted and
um but I think I'll always still
struggle with you know just as a just as
a
a former alcoholic is probably always
going to have to be on guard against you
know having another drink I think a
former workaholic is always going to
have to be on guard when it comes to
making choices that very you know
quickly can put you back into
destructive habits
the way I've tried to make peace with it
is I need people I got two little kids I
need people out there solving some of
these big complex issues at the local
level and at the national level the
global level
I want people out there really going for
it and I've had to look in the mirror
and say you can go for it
but that call from Dad's not coming
that that that certificate's not going
to come in the mail that says hey I'm
really proud it's not going to come
right that's it it's not going to solve
me and that may be the ultimate
skyscraper I wanted to build right
um I want to do all this and achieve all
of this because then it it then then I
finally sew up that hole inside and it
just
I don't know so I I guess I I want
people to achieve I just wanted to know
that it's not going to heal you you got
to do that work somewhere else
yeah and I I think that you know
building off what you're saying I mean I
think a bigger skyscraper for me is
after I'm dead like nobody remembers me
other than my kids and my grandkids and
my friends like that that's to me that's
a legacy worth having
um not
to 10 years after I'm dead someone's
writing an article about me like it I
that just doesn't mean anything zero
yeah um yeah so so so knowing that after
my kids go to college they actually want
to come home knowing that after my kids
get married they actually want to be
near us they want to you know they want
to call me when they have a problem I
mean those are things that are going to
matter far more to me than
any and anything else I'm doing
can you give us some granular not even
granular some simple let's go with
simple
if somebody's listening to this and they
don't even know what metabolic Health
means if Alzheimer's is something that
happened to their grandmother and that's
a problem for future them
can we talk through what's metabolic
health and what are a couple of things
people can start thinking about right
now wherever they happen to be and
cognitive Health down the road we start
thinking about some of those things what
are some things we can do right now to
be intentional about playing a 20 or 30
or 40 or 50 year game
so metabolic Health basically comes down
to does your body know what to do with
energy does it know where to store it
and does it know how best to access it
that's that's that's the simplest
definition I can come up with and what
differentiates a metabolically healthy
person from a metabolically unhealthy
person is that distinction so let's
consider somebody with type 2 diabetes
versus someone who's in perfect
metabolic health
one difference is that the person with
Type 2 Diabetes by definition has very
elevated blood sugar
the glucose in their plasma is probably
twice as high as the glucose in the
plasma of the healthy person so right
away you know they have a storage
problem they don't know how to dispose
of all that glucose
the other storage problem they have is
they are putting fat which can be safely
stored in fat cells subcutaneous fat
cells they're putting it in places where
it's unhealthy to store it they're
putting it around their organs in their
pancreas inside their muscles directly
and all of these things create
inflammation exacerbate insulin
resistance and kick off the Cascade that
is the reason why somebody with type 2
diabetes has a you know 50 to 100
percent higher risk of succumbing to
cancer heart disease Alzheimer's disease
on the retrieval side there's also
something broken when you're
metabolically unhealthy which is when
you're doing low rent work you should be
consuming fatty acids right when you're
just sitting around doing nothing not
demanding incredible amounts of energy
you should be oxidizing in the most
efficient way possible fatty acids
in fact even under moderate moderate
um you know levels of exertional stress
you know low intensity exercise you
should still be able to do this mostly
with your mitochondria
but again a metabolically unhealthy
person can't they're basically
constantly on a glucose treadmill
and so again we could get into kind of
the Weeds on all that but but at a
fundamental level that's the problem
right the metabolically unhealthy person
doesn't store energy correctly and they
don't Access Energy correctly
and so
if you think of nothing else
simply making sure you're as
metabolically healthy as possible
is the most important thing to do more
important than specifically thinking
about what do I need to do around
Alzheimer's disease heart disease and
cancer I mean again if someone wants to
go deep down the rabbit hole
as I do great lock yourself out there's
a operating manual sitting right next to
you but if you just want to think big
picture what do I need to do to be as
metabolically healthy as possible
Step One is exercise I mean there is no
substitute for the benefit of exercise
in fact it is impossible to be
metabolically unhealthy if your muscle
mass is you know at the 90th percentile
for your age and sex and your VO2 max is
at the 90th percentile for your age and
sex if you are in that category if your
cardio respiratory Fitness and your
muscle mass and strength are at the 90th
percentile for your agent sex which by
the way is not impossible to do in this
Society
but your problem is solved now you can't
get there without exercising without
being somewhat mindful of how you're
eating without sleeping adequately like
if you're sleeping three hours a night
it's going to be very difficult to do
that you could get away with it when
you're younger going to be a lot harder
when you're older
um so everything else really just needs
to be in service of that and and again
people I think just major in the minor
and minor in the major on some of this
stuff it's like oh should I be on this
diet or this diet or this diet it's like
it doesn't matter that much be in energy
balance get sufficient amounts of
protein
um and you know focus on how much you're
exercising in your sleep and and that
you're you're gonna get like two-thirds
of all the benefit is going to come
through that type of adherence I had a I
had a great com uh I call it my come to
Lane meeting and I kept hitting laying
up lanes and close but hey what about
this what about this what about this
what about this what about this and he
finally said if you will exercise and
you will
control energy consumption and you will
sleep
then call me about your cold tub and
we'll talk like man it's just I just
want it to be such bells and whistles
and it's just not it's just not sexy at
all
um
do you have any Lane and I have had that
I think Lane and I joked once that um
you shouldn't be allowed to make a
single comment on Twitter about
nutrition
until you do a hundred push-ups first so
every time you want to tweet something
about nutrition do 100 push-ups then you
can go back to your phone or computer
put your little nutrition tweet out
there and then if you feel like doing it
again in 10 minutes get back down do 100
push-ups and then go and do it again
that's it but you can tweet as much as
you want about nutrition you just have
to do 100 push-ups before you do it
every time that the same can be applied
to your sauna protocol your cold plunge
protocol
look I love sauna and cold lunch but you
know if if you think that that's the
thing that's going to get you to the
promised land at the expense of doing
any exercise or watching what you eat
the promised land the promised land is
going to be a dark place for you just
yeah you sit in the cold plunge with
your tall boys in a hot dog
just being real excited
do you have any sort of framework that I
might be able to communicate broadly
when I think of Frameworks I think of
one grad school Professor I have and Dr
Tia like just it feels like you think of
the world in cubes Maybe I'm Wrong just
in frames
how folks without years of training
um I know how much
graduate school had to sit and just chip
away and chip away and chip away and I
know how much I struggle
to just consume a headline and then
click through it and try to find the
original source and then go find and I
don't have access to my journals like I
used to have at the University so it's
behind a paywall or it's got some very
broad you know introduction
how do you find good information in this
Magnum ecosystem that just comes at US
24 7 is there any sort of road map you
can give us
no unfortunately it is a there's a
there's a pretty low if not non-existent
signal to noise ratio when it comes to
information about health
um you know one thing you can do is sort
of find some reputable aggregators of
studies so there are a couple of
newsletters I subscribe to you know a
couple weeklies monthlies where you know
somewhat people who I trust uh are
aggregating and sending out links to
depending on the newsletter 20 to 50
articles so I can pretty quickly skim
through that and say okay like these are
the 10 this week that I'm going to
you know skim
um of course I'm also a cheater because
I have a research team so I get to at
this point now because I'm being pulled
in many directions kick a lot of it to
them and say okay
these three look interesting let's let's
let's go deeper on these things but
basically there's kind of no substitute
for learning how to read scientific
studies
um and you do have to go I mean you
certainly can't rely on what you know
pop news is doing I mean any any you
know the headline sort of grabbing
nonsenses you shouldn't be reading that
at all you should at a minimum go to the
study
um even sometimes you'll just read the
abstract and you'll realize the abstract
is completely at odds with what the
headline of this of the you know article
was I mean and usually you know at that
point you know it's really problematic
but nothing is worse than reading the
abstract and getting through the
conclusion and thinking that's not what
that was at all that's not what this
study was at all for those listening to
abstract is simply a summary of a paper
that they put at the introduction so
um a lot of
my colleagues and friends will read a
bunch of abstracts and
I think they know a lot of stuff and
actually not pull the article apart
which makes her all kind of chaos down
the road especially journalists can can
be uh guilty of that but
um
it was a strange ecosystem where you've
got Dr Atia you got Lane you got these
folks putting up this information that
has been hidden behind grad school
professors for centuries
just putting it up for free here you go
and then you've got the essential oil
salesman and the the new hot Pilates in
mud I don't know whatever you know just
drop flowers over your head and I I
don't whatever charlatans and it's all
in the same channel it's all in the same
river
and the number of times I sit with
people at a conference if I'm speaking
at a conference and they've got a hey I
just read that you got to have a bowl of
blueberries with it's like man that's
ah I just wanna I I don't know what to
say because you just nod and
have a great day I mean we we do you
know if folks are interested they can
sign up for our newsletter and every
Sunday we put out an article and usually
that article is some examination of a
paper and or
um you know a popular press article that
was referencing some study and
it's kind of just one of those things
where you just got to get the Reps like
you just have to go through and see okay
look this is how Peter and his team
dissect this over and over and over
again and it's I mean we have a treasure
Trove of these things if people ever
want to go back and read them it's you
know we've only been doing it for 12
years now so I'll tell everybody all the
way back from your nerd Safari Days
there are a few things worth your
investment in time than to go the way
you so simply pull these things apart
these research studies apart and show
yeah it looks this way but here's what
it's actually saying and here's the
problems with this study and here's why
you can't just start mainlining Diet
Cokes because of this or they did this
in a Petri dish or they gave this to a
bunch of rats it's so helpful and so for
the last yeah you've been doing a long
long time but we'll link to that in the
show notes man yeah and and you yeah I
forgot about nerd Safari so there was
that whole series we did in the nerd
Safari called studying studies I think
it's a five or six part series we did in
2018 and then I think Lane has recently
come up with something called reps which
is a program that he's launched that's
uh similarly geared towards kind of
helping people understand how to
um how to interpret it how to interpret
scientific papers yeah all right um
couple more and then we'll get out of
here
I want to dig into movement and
particularly stability
one of the stunning things you've
brought to my life was that
Falls
Falling Down is increases your mortality
risk especially as you age like nothing
else does so why is movement and
stability the way we move so critical to
our long-term emotional and physical
health
I mean I think it's just kind of an
empirical observation of having watched
people later in life that even if
they're cognitively sharp throughout
life
the total Destruction
of their capacity to move
um you know I think diminishes quality
of life in a way that I don't think we
talk about enough so
um
you know we we lose
power we lose strength at a relatively
young age I mean we lose you know our
power probably peaks in our mid-20s our
strength probably peaks in our 40s
um
and it's sort of a downhill slide from
there if we're not really really working
hard on those things
um and when you couple you know the site
so so stability is such a complicated
topic that it warranted its own chapter
in the book because it's really that
difficult to to explain what it means
but you know it's it's it's basically
the property of the body that allows the
body to transmit Force to the outside
world
um without energy dissipation and injury
and vice versa for the outside world to
transmit Force to us without energy
dissipation and injury and
virtually every chronic injury you can
think of and frankly many acute injuries
that are basically just acute injuries
on chronic weaknesses are the result of
some sort of instability and
you know if you look at you know the
typical repetitive use injury you know
someone who walking upstairs their knee
is hurting I mean if you study their
biomechanics you'll very quickly see
some movement pattern where force is not
being transmitted correctly through the
joint so there's an energy leak in the
knee maybe it's you know there's a
valgus inward maybe the foot is
collapsing and that is transmitting pain
or transmitting a force laterally
through the knee so all of these things
um
you know constitute what I think of as
an important part of strength training
that's somewhat distinct from strength
training itself so you you can't
overstate the value of lifting heavy
things
um it's just
so important I mean my my kids are my
boys are you know six and almost six and
almost nine and when they come in the
gym with me and you know they like to do
push-ups and sit-ups and things like
that but mostly I'm like guys just pick
up those dumbbells and walk around with
them like that's kind of the only thing
that matters right now is just let's
develop that grip strength let's develop
the scapular stability let's develop the
balance that's necessary to move
something heavy
um
but on top of that I think you do want
to be training in these movement
patterns in the book I talk about too
but you have to be sort of Bruce Lee
about this stuff you have to sort of
look at all modalities absorbed what is
useful disregard what is useless I talk
at length about DNS and PRI as two
systems
um which for me have produced the best
results but you have to go out and
figure out what's working for you for
some people it might be Pilates right it
might be that you know Pilates is the
way that they're gonna sort of stabilize
everything from their core to their
shoulders to you know their hips to
their knees like um
so
if this doesn't happen and you find
yourself in that situation where in the
last decade of your life you
you know you can't pick up a grandkid
off the floor you can't sit on the floor
and play you can't get up off the floor
um you're confined to a chair you can't
really walk up a flight of stairs if you
walk you can't walk quick enough to walk
with anyone I mean these things that we
all take for granted today physically
for most people they become
very difficult to do in the eighth or
ninth decade of life
so again there's there's something about
being intentional
at 20 30 and 40. it's just like it's
just investing right I'm just putting
money away I'm doing something hard in
the short term in the in the in the
future I mean the presence so that my
futures
got peace it's very much like investing
yeah I mean it really is
um and there is a
there is a matter of you know hyperbolic
discounting it's not natural to us to
invest I think what's even better what
makes everything we're talking about
here better than just the you know the
401K analogy is
there truly is no upside in the present
to saving for your 401k right like if
you get a thousand dollar paycheck every
week after tax
and you choose to put 200 of that into
your 401k there's no other way to look
at it you have 200 fewer dollars today
you're not getting you're not getting
anything out of that now
I think any financial advisor will tell
you you're still net positive in life
because of what that's going to mean
when you're 65 or whenever you decide to
start making withdrawals
but here's the thing
if you've got
eight hours a week when you could be
screwing around and you choose to put
six of those hours a week into exercise
and screw around for two hours
you actually get something for it today
everything in your life is better yeah
everything is better today and in the
future imagine if a 401k were that
rewarding imagine if putting 200 away
today gave you 400 today and 400
tomorrow yes
that's what exercises that's an
incredible analogy I love that I love
that picture
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
Let's uh wrap this up
um one of the
so when I left the academic environment
the research environment and came to a
media company
one of the things I noticed right out
the gate was my friends that I had
dinner parties with that I was rubbing
shoulders with during the day my friends
who regardless of their discipline I
just called them all scientists who were
studying things their goal was to always
be less wrong and so the most acute
example of that is when covet kicked off
and maybe it was I think it was King's
College whoever it happened to be throws
this model down and says
30 million people are going to die
to my scientist friends who were in
those in that world it was game on like
excellent we're going to take our models
and our people and our computer systems
and we're going to use their models in
new data coming in and within two weeks
hey we think it's going to be 15 million
and so if you look at that in in the
community where I come from there's this
there's this cheer 15 million less
people are going to be dead per this
model
and on and on and on it goes
it was looking at the political realm
and the media realm which I was
blissfully unaware of that realized
there's no there's no
we got new information button here
so one of the great gifts you've brought
to my life for the last decade is
approaching all the things I think I
know all the people who I'm honored to
sit kneecap to kneecap with
and be very humble about it
so I want to ask you a couple of
questions about humility
first one is
you surround yourself with the best of
the best voices across the world and if
I were to look at you I don't know
anybody who has the conglomerate of
knowledge in one skull like you do
what's the value of bringing in coaches
and other people to watch you
when really you've got the answers right
you've got these great therapists and
great coaches and great people behind
closed doors walking alongside you
I would look at you from the outside and
say dude you don't need that you've got
all the information
what's the value of a coach
oh well I mean I look we could answer
this broadly or we could answer this
personally let's just start with the
obvious is there one
top performer that doesn't have a coach
I mean like wouldn't the wouldn't I mean
last time I checked I'm pretty sure
LeBron James had specific you know
coaches and gurus Tom Brady you know
right up until he retired would have
been surrounded by people who were doing
anything and everything to give him the
edge and make him better so yeah it's
hard for me to imagine that there's
anyone who would ever get so good that
they would not want any help they could
get to be better
and if that's true of the top performers
in the world then it's it's clearly true
for me because if you think about it
where I'm
I mean I think of this in two ways right
I think of this if on a personal level
you know therapists and things like that
well
yeah they're helping me because I'm
actually not very good right yeah I mean
I I I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm not even in the
professional leagues yet right I'm I'm
the I'm the fledgling Arena quarterback
who's trying to get good and uh who's
but he's fortunate enough to be able to
get good coaches and people to try to
help him and then on the professional
side I mean to me that's the joy of
having a podcast is it's just a
fantastic reason to be able to sort of
sit down and talk with people who are
subject matter experts on things that I
find interesting so
um at least for my podcast and my
subject matter they're aligned right
like I get to
you know this my professional interest
is in doing this thing and now I get to
interview people who are the best at
their respective disciplines that more
broadly constitute what I'm interested
in so well my hope is that the meta
lesson there is not lost which is
true expertise is saying the magic words
I don't know let me find out not I've
got this just infinite
system running at all times in my mind
that has every answer and every nuanced
every every rabbit hole right I guess
that's maybe that's the the most
unmooring part of the social media
ecosystem which is this idea that there
is a person with all of the answers
versus true expertise and true wisdom is
I don't know man let me find out I know
a guy I know her she's she's brilliant
which seems to be a much it just seems
to be much more peaceful way to make
your way through the world but
um you're somebody that on the outside
yeah I don't agree with you I don't know
anybody who's the best at what they do
but man I know a lot of folks who are
very proud to not ask for help and a lot
of folks who have all the answers
because Google said so and I'm just
plowing ahead through life and
um man what a gift to have people in
your world that you take a knee to and
say you can look at this problem from a
different angle that's such a gift tell
me something you've changed your mind on
in the last decade
you're so deliberate it appears to be
that you're so deliberate on decision
making and choice what's something
you're pretty bullish on back in the day
and you thought nah it's kind of a waste
of my time
oh and I I don't think we have another
hour so I'll try to limit this
um
well certainly around nutrition I've
changed my mind on a lot right I I I've
and I talk about this in one of the
chapters on nutrition but
look there was a day when I I really
thought that
um
you know carbohydrate restriction was
probably the most important tool to
health
um I I don't believe that today there
was a day when I believed that nutrition
as a broad topic was more important to
health than exercise
I don't believe that today wow that's
Matt for those who don't know that's
that's massive
that's a significant shift
um
I would say there was a day when I
didn't believe that emotional health
mattered at all in any of this uh
equation if you will and I clearly don't
believe that today so those would be
those would be just the top three that
come to my mind
what would be something that you thought
was awfully woo-woo 10 years ago that
has become a core part of your life
sauna
tell me more
well I think you know I I had previously
looked at the sauna data and which are
from an epidemiologic standpoint pretty
impressive in terms of disease risk
reduction especially around
cardiovascular disease and
neurodegenerative disease uh well
dementia specifically and Alzheimer's
disease and you know I had just
consistently discounted those data and
said it was all healthy user bias there
were too many confounders like I just
didn't buy any of it
um
while I don't believe that the benefit
of sauna is as strong as the
epidemiology suggests because I do think
that there are still confounders and
healthy user biases and all those things
I don't think it needs to be to still be
valuable if the benefit is half as good
as the epidemiology
um I think it's still
a very valuable Roi and
um I say that for many reasons but of
course you know the Epi is very
consistent it's all in the same
direction you have the mechanistic data
you have the dose effect there are lots
of you know you can go through kind of
What's called the Austin Bradford Hill
criteria of epidemiology and start to
try to infer what's the probability that
there is causality in this Association
and I think it's I think there is
causality there
um and so well there I go learning
something that I do I had I had still
had that in behind essential oils man so
uh that's well
that's another conversation I need to
have with my wife then we have to move
some stuff around the garage then we've
got to get one
um hey wrapping up this show
um again thank you thank you
um
I know there's nothing more precious in
the world than your time so thank you I
usually wrap this show up
um I'm a long time
music lover and I grew up going to the
punk clubs there in Houston where I grew
up and in West Texas out there and I
live in Nashville of course
um
I end the show with a song of the day do
you have a favorite song
that when nobody's around you turn it up
and you may still get a little emotional
and you're singing a little bit too loud
no but because you're in Nashville can
we just do like I don't know something
by Taylor Swift hey how are they was she
amazing
she was amazing my the associate
producer she really is something else
the associate producer went to all the
shows just
yeah we've talked about Taylor quite a
bit on this show just truly incredible
I'll I'll explain that uh as we wrap up
the show you can go back you can go back
to your world that uh you have quite the
quite the the love for Taylor Swift
um yes we'll pick it you have a favorite
what's your favorite I I mean my
daughter and I talk no no it's hard for
me to give you a favorite but but I
really I really love ready for it
um excellent you know I I love the the
the Great War maroon uh demand like
there's just so many like I could give
you my top 10 and you could pick how's
that that hey you know what
you've just shamed all of us but now but
now this means my daughter's gonna I'm
gonna actually have my daughter watch
this podcast and say you got it you
gotta watch the whole the whole thing
all the way through do not turn it off
till the very very end that sounds this
just gave me an awesome reason well
brother
um the book is out live and I'll talk
about this extensively in the show
opener I've I've even worn I've torn the
cover off I've been digging into this
thing so much and this needs to be
honest I was about to say did Amazon rip
you no I
I my wife tells me I don't treat books
with the dignity they deserve and I like
I just once I get one I get my hands on
it I just kind of become a mess but no
this is mine that's good at least you
you get to see the little design that I
fought for with the little Archer on the
on the cover there man I'm grateful for
you thank you for
changing hearts and Minds in little
podcast earbuds all across the country
man starting with me and my family I'm
grateful for you blessings to you there
and take care of my home state of Texas
and uh we will connect soon
thank you very much
all right we are back
guys amazing such a such a he's a
National Treasure
um we're gonna link to everything in the
show notes we'll link to his website
into his podcast and to his newsletter
it's it's a newsletter that I subscribe
to
um it's worth your time reading it on
Sunday mornings or Sunday afternoons
as we wrap up this show
per his request
and shout out to his lovely daughter
today's song of the day is by the great
Almighty and Powerful
Taylor Swift in The song is called ready
for it and it goes like this
knew he was a killer first time that I
saw him wondered how many girls he had
loved and left haunted but if he's a
ghost then I can be a phantom God she's
so good holding him for ransom some some
boys are trying too hard he don't try at
all though younger than my exes but he
act like such a man so I see nothing
better I keep him forever like a
vendetta
Jenna I gotta give it to you man she's
the best of the best of the best
I I see how this is gone go touch me and
you'll never be alone Island Breeze and
lights down low no one has to know in
the middle of the night in my dreams you
should see the things we do baby in the
middle of the night in my dreams I know
I'm gonna be with you so I take my time
are you ready for it
so good so good
and I'm smiling like a little kid
walking away from a high five God I'm so
grateful for you guys we'll see you soon
[Music]